I love the novelist Lawrence Durrell.
Here's why
in the prefatory note to derails novel
who's are he writes,
modern literature offers us know
humanities,
so I have turned to science and I'm
trying to complete a four decker novel
whose form is based on the relativity
proposition.
Three sides of space,
and one of time constitute a soup mix of
a continuum.
The four novels follow this pattern.
Darryl's masterpiece.
The Alexandria Quartet is modeled after
this concept.
The first three novels tell of the same
series of events from different
perspectives with each new novel
recontextualizing what actually
happened.
These represent the three dimensions of
space and show that one perspective can
never illustrate the whole picture.
The fourth and final novel revisits
these same characters five years later,
adding the additional perspective of
time,
creating a continuum.
Now,
many people,
including drls friends,
have noted that saying,
the Alexandria Quartet is a model of the
space time continuum is nothing but a
semantic device.
These people are of course,
write a continuum of the store can only
be expressed in mathematics and not in
words,
but just as,
for example,
the mercator projection is meant to give
the impression of a sphere derails.
Quartet is only meant to give the
impression of a continue as special
relativity forced us to see reality in a
new way.
The form of the quartet does the same
thing with the concept of personality as
space and time are relative to each
other.
Personalities are relative to other
personalities.
As Darryl's character,
our says,
each psyche is really an anthill of
opposing predispositions.
Personality as something with fixed
attributes is an illusion.
I would go even further and say that
personality as exclusive to one person
is an illusion as well dwells.
Continuum,
like representation of a group of lovers
and friends that picks what the
nightvale podcasts,
twitter handle put so succinctly a few
days ago.
A name is ally that keeps you from
thinking that you might be more than one
single.
B,
it seems to me that the separation of
objects in space leads us to believe
that we ourselves are separate from the
ones we love,
when in truth we blend into and warp one
another in the same way that time and
space do.
In the presence of supermassive objects.
I am an active part of the personalities
of my friends,
just as my friends are active
constituents of my personnel.
Drl is so important to me because in the
Alexandria Quartet and later in the
Avignon Quintet,
the basic unit of humanity is never an
individual but a group of friends,
and to depict the complexity of that
unit,
drl has to contextualize and
recontextualize until multiple people
begin to feel like one organism.
He finds the model in four dimensional
space time and it comes off brilliantly.
It's the kind of work that breaks down
our self conceptions and shows us what
we is.
If there's a used bookstore around you,
go find something by Darrelle.
The Alexandria Quartet is obviously my
favorite and I think it's the best.
Here's are,
and I have some other.
Justine phalluses are mount,
Mount Olive and clay,
and also I'm reading right now the first
of the heavy on Quintet,
which is called Matsuura.